para un público no colombiano que no
conozca tanto la política interna de
colombia podría explicar quién es álvaro
uribe y por qué ahora se ha desligado un
poco más de la campaña presidencial
por supuesto álvaro uribe es un político
antioqueño que tuvo una figuración muy
importante
como una figura que se contraponía a los
procesos de diálogo con las antiguas
guerrillas de las farc fue un político
de origen o de origen liberal pero luego
tomó su propio camino
y creó su propia colectividad primero
con un partido político denominado
primero colombia luego creó el partido
de la voy más adelante el centro
democrático cuando ese partido de la u
fue
tomado por en su otrora como partidario
y luego también presidente juan manuel
santos el expresidente uribe es tal vez
la figura
digamos de mayor impacto en la
ciudadanía en décadas en colombia y tuvo
un respaldo muy muy importante
por parte de grupos poblacionales
cansados agotados de la violencia
de digamos afectados también en buena
medida por prácticas muy complejas del
conflicto armado de
prácticas como el secuestro extorsivo
inclusivo inclusive
los secuestros donde donde se tenían
confinados a muchas personas militares
políticos empresarios en una suerte de
campos de concentración por parte del
grupo en ese momento de las farc todo
ese todos los reclamos digamos que
fueron fueron muy bien recogidos por
parte de álvaro uribe y su colectividad
y fueron canalizados entonces en un
respaldo electoral
durante muchos años tal vez los últimos
cuatro periodos de gobierno en colombia
excepto la reelección de juan manuel
santos
han sido periodos de gobierno en los que
álvaro uribe ha prácticamente definido
en la elección entonces estamos hablando
de la figura política de mayor
trascendencia en el país en en texas
sin embargo una vez superado el
conflicto armado por lo menos en
términos de una buena parte del de la
antigua guerrilla de las farc gracias al
al proceso de negociación y al acuerdo
que finalmente se logró entre el
gobierno y esta antigua guerrilla pues
ha hecho que se superen muchas de las
dificultades que en el debate público y
en la opinión pública existen alrededor
de la violencia por supuesto que que aún
persisten algunos grupos que existe y
persiste violencia política en el país
de diferente naturaleza claro que sí
pero en el discurso y en el y en el
digamos en el debate público el
argumento en torno a la seguridad ya no
es un argumento tan fuerte precisamente
porque pues el hecho de haber logrado un
acuerdo y de que muy muy buena parte de
la exguerrilla se encuentre en la vida
civil pues hace que la preocupación por
temas públicos vaya hacia otros en otras
direcciones entonces hay un agotamiento
de ese discurso que en su momento fue el
discurso que catapultó a álvaro uribe ya
su colectividad ese ya no es el discurso
digamos que está calando en la opinión
pública y hay también un agotamiento de
los gobiernos en los que ha tenido una
un gran impacto en esta figura de álvaro
uribe vélez entonces creo que lo que
estamos viendo hoy y lo que veremos
seguramente las próximas elecciones ya
en primera vuelta propiamente es
prácticamente ese agotamiento con con
esa orientación digamos dada por por
álvaro uribe y una orientación digamos
que podríamos identificar como de
de derecha en el país y estamos entonces
dando un giro o siendo testigos de un
giro del país político un poco más hacia
el centro y algo de la izquierda